thank you
good morning everybody thank you for
being here this morning
i want to start off by making a a
request please uh
parking is very limited in this facility
and obviously we're very concentrated on
trying to make sure staff can get out of
here in and out of here safely and
continue to count ballots so
keep in mind that we're going to be
adding uh security at all of our
entrances and they'll only be granting
access to those who are approved members
of the media
members of my staff and those
individuals who have
uh business with the election department
so please keep that in mind
the purpose of being here this morning
is to give some clarification on exactly
what the work is that's being done here
in clark county to get the votes counted
accurately
i have counts now
on what we received from the election
day drop-offs
the us postal service on election day
and yesterday
and also some additional ballots that we
had pending
because we had to stop processing to
begin getting ready for election day
support
so on election day at the drop-off
locations at all vote centers on the
election department there were thirty
four thousand seven hundred and forty
three ballots dropped off
the u.s postal service as of election
day and yesterday
brought to us four thousand two hundred
and eight ballots
and there were twenty four thousand
three hundred and eleven ballots
that were pending when we stopped
processing to get ready for election day
so that brings us to a total of sixty
three thousand two hundred
sixty two today staff is preparing to
count
and has already begun counting a little
over fifty one thousand ballots that
will be reported tomorrow
uh prior to my ten a.m brief
it's important that everybody understand
that there are also additional ballots
that are pending outside of what i just
described
so i'm briefly going to go through those
the provisional uh ballots that were
cast during the early voting and
election day
the first announcement that i need to
make is that the posting that was placed
on our website
on election night and yesterday was
incorrect
we determined that our tabulation
software was
incorrectly duplicating those records
and so the 120
000 that you may have seen on our
website is an incorrect number that has
been corrected
and the post that is out on our website
now at www.clarkcountynv.gov forward
slash vote
is correct and those professional
ballots number
a little over sixty thousand
we have to coordinate very closely with
the secretary of state
we are a bottom up not a top-down voter
registration jurisdiction
and so all 17 counties need to send
information to the secretary because
there's
not one single database that we all draw
from we all have our own
and so in coordinating with the
secretary of state we're awaiting
instructions from them
on when to send our provisional listing
up to them
because we need to make absolutely
certain that nobody who's casted a
provisional ballot here in clark county
has done so in another county
so we're waiting instructions from them
on when to send that report so we can
make that verification
staff is still currently working on all
of those provisional ballots to make
determinations as to whether the voter
was
eligible to cast that provisional ballot
that work will be ready once we notify
the secretary of state and it is an
automated process to pass those
provisional ballots into the tabulation
system
we have a group of voters who are id
required
for one reason or another the deadline
for those voters to get back to us
is friday november 6th at 5 pm
so that is another group of ballots that
we will need to
put into the system once they have come
in to provide their
id the u.s mail will continue to deliver
so starting tomorrow through next
tuesday which is the last day for us to
receive
a mail ballot that's been postmarked
november third
we will continue to receive mail so
again those ballots are also separate
from what i previously reported
the cure process in nevada which is
statutorily required for those voters
who have been notified that either did
not sign their ballot
or their signature did not match in our
system
they have until thursday november 12th
to cure that ballot
the last day that we can tabulate and
send ballots into the system
is november 12th so
that night we will stay here until we
are done entering ballots into the
system because
statute clearly tells us that we must be
done counting by that date
with that information i hope that i've
clarified a lot of the questions
we are anticipating to have the bulk of
our mail ballot
that have been received into the system
by saturday or
sunday those ballots that are coming in
through the u s
mail or that are being cured will be a
small number
and we will continue to put those in but
the bulk of our ballots we're hoping
will be read by saturday or sunday
this weekend and again we won't complete
until november 12th with all of those
other ballots that serve as exceptions
so with that information i've got a
short period of time here where i can
answer some questions from you
my response is that we are not aware of
any improper ballots that are being
processed
not directly that i'm aware of and
there's also some concern
[Music]
i think it's important for the entire
country to understand that mail ballots
on this scale is very new to the state
of nevada
we made a decision here to provide as
much access as we possibly could as a
result of the pandemic
and so our processes run a little bit
slower
we also have to make sure that our data
is being updated because we need to
prevent
people from voting twice in the system
and so we have to scan those in as mail
received so that it updates the database
so our in-person voters
can't have voted twice we're still
receiving information from our election
day laptops that'll be complete today
so we're going to update and make sure
that all of the information was
downloaded from all 300 of those laptops
that were used on election day
to make sure that the automated system
will reject mail ballots for somebody
who has voted on election day
so our goal here in clark county is not
to count fast
we want to make sure that we're being
accurate the results in the state of
nevada obviously are going to be very
important to the entire country and that
is our number one goal
what's the outstanding number one more
time the outstanding number
that just went through the whole thing
what's the total what is the two well i
i went through a long process how about
we get together after this
why is it taking so long if you can
count 70 000 a day
i think i just answered that question
you said deliberately but
if you have the capacity why aren't you
doing it because they're not available
sir there are many steps in the process
so the first process is that we run it
through our agilis machine
then there are two manual processes then
it goes to the counting board
and then it goes to tabulation
i need you to speak up sir i can't hear
your questions
i did not say they were already counted
i said today the staff is prepared to
count 51 000 ballots that are ready to
be counted today
those will be reported tomorrow at 10
a.m right there next to you
folks i really need you all to speak up
i cannot hear you
those are separate and that's why i
listed in my statement that those are
separate from the numbers that are
reported
first we don't i don't have that number
with me
mr gloria to be to summarize and help us
all
how many ballots are left to count
that's a number that i can't give you i
can't predict to you what's going to
come through the u.s mail
so i deliberately went through all of
these numbers and i was hoping that you
all would
take the information that i'm providing
but there's a set number
of ballots that we know are available to
be processed and that's the 60
63 000 then i mentioned all of the other
additional ballots
so we again again we plan to cut
to be able to have counted the majority
of our mail ballots
by saturday or sunday and then all of
those other ballots
that were statutorily limited i can't
count all the mail ballots till i have
them and we have to continue to accept
them up until tuesday
november 10. to repeat the numbers so
that we were clear
it was 6-3-2-6-2 that is
this
correct
[Music]
i personally dealt with miss stoke she
brought her claim to me
we reviewed the ballot and in our
opinion it's her signature
we also gave her an opportunity to
provide a statement
if she wanted to object to that and
provide a challenge to that she refused
to do so
a member of the nevada secretary of
state's office investigation team also
interviewed her and they had no issue
with the assistance that we tried to
give her
i have nothing else to comment on that
next question
i can tell you that my wife and my
mother are very concerned for me but
we have security here we have law
enforcement who are protecting us i am
concerned for the safety of my staff
we're putting measures into place to
make sure that we have the security
that's necessary again we're going to
begin to monitor
the vehicles as they come in to make
sure that they should be here and that
they're parking properly so that we
don't prevent
our employees from having an issue
getting in and out of the facility but
i i feel safe we're going to be okay
we're going to continue to count we will
not allow anyone to stop us from doing
what our duty is
in counting ballots
[Music]
make yes to every registered electorate
of nevada and that was a violation of
the old rules
plus that they have not been allowed to
observe closely
all the accounting
the first part of your question relates
to action that was taken by the nevada
legislature
i don't make policy i'm simply an
administrator so the nevada legislature
acted in the summer
and we carried through that exactly what
they prescribed for us to do
as far as your second issue that issue's
been litigated
and the judge ruled in our favor
louder please
those are reports that we're going to
generate after the election once we
start getting ready to do our canvas
so that's information that i'll have
available once we've done all of our
work counted all the ballots
and if we have enough proof we will
definitely going out
to arrest these people because those are
obviously illegal actions but
that's an activity that needs to take
place once we've done
counting and getting the canvas done
most of these voters have been notified
and they actually voted because they
voted provisionally and we're told they
didn't have the id
that they needed in order to do that
these are also mail ballot voters who
were also notified that they needed to
provide an id
on the envelope that's sent out to them
and they failed to do so so
they've been notified and the deadline
is tomorrow at 5 pm
i know that there are several people who
are working
to actively reach out to those voters
and try to help them get in with that id
there was a question over here yes right
there
it depends on the status of our mail
ballot process we are running ships in
certain areas
so we work anytime uh
bearing from 5 a.m up to 10 or 11
o'clock at night
uh we don't run the 24-hour shifts that
you see running in other states because
the work that comes through on the mail
ballot process is very deliberate as it
moves forward
and so we complete the work that's done
in each stage and then the next day it
carries forward to the next again i
emphasize
what i'm trying to report here is that
clark county looks like we'll be able to
count the majority
of our mail ballots by saturday or
sunday however there are other ballots
as a result of statutory requirements
that we'll have to continue to reap
because we have to take ballots until
next
have tuesday these briefings on saturday
and sunday
absolutely i will be here at 10 a.m
until we're done
we're going to coincide with the
secretary of state i think it's very
important that as a state all 17 of the
counties
are working to coordinate with the
secretary who is our chief election
officer
so she has reported that she put out
today at nine we followed suit and we
reported today
if the secretary makes a decision not to
report
from here on out we are going to have to
report so
if we have results to report we will do
it on a daily basis as i mentioned
we're going to do a 10 a.m brief to give
you all an opportunity to ask questions
and our updates should be posted prior
to that brief
right there
any individual who had an issue with
their mail ballot should have contacted
us prior to election day
we are here to help the voter i have
been on many zoom interviews many media
interviews many
organizational groups throughout the
county letting them know that if you
have an issue with your ballot whatever
it may be
call 455 vote however they're past that
process
the election is over we're in the
process of counting at this point
right there
you know that's available on our website
i don't have that number right off the
top of my head but you can quickly see
that on our website on our enr report
right there
i'm sorry ma'am i can't hear you i'm
part of hearing and we're in the
warehouse
regardless of any reports that you're
referring to the numbers that i just
gave
you are the ones you should go with
don't try to calculate it for yourself
i just told you that there are sixty
three thousand two hundred and sixty two
and then there are exceptions so i can't
answer any of your questions because
you're drawing from data that i didn't
calculate
yeah but that's not what i used to
generate i purposely set up this
interview so that we could make sure and
clear this up
you're drawing your data from somebody
somewhere else and you want me to answer
according that number
i can't that's why i gave you this
information
a next question right there
i can't give you a probability on that
what i can tell you is that we're firm
in our
commitment to making sure that we're
processing ballots with high integrity
in the state of nevada
a lot of that that depends on anybody
who's aware of something they feel that
may have been nefarious they need to
notify our office and we'll get the
nevada secretary of state
involved with investigating that but
we're doing everything we can
to uphold the integrity of the process
here in clark county
absolutely we're very committed here we
have a strong
history in clark county of leading in
our processes and the use of technology
and working to keep things high in
integrity with everything
i do and we do as a team credit to my
staff for their commitment as well in
the hours they've worked
but what i really want to also hit home
on and this is for election
administrators across the country i'm
sure they agree with me
we're not concerned with breeding as
fast as we can we are concerned with
making sure that we're accurate in what
we report
because this is a very important
election in the state of nevada it may
make the decision for the president
so we take that very seriously and we
will make sure
that we're doing everything properly joe
using your numbers
and everybody's watching you want to be
clear
63 262 and you inspect the count
51 000 today that means
most should be counted by tomorrow
that's not what i said
i've said it many times clark county is
looking like
we will complete the bulk of our mail
ballot account
by saturday and sunday after that there
are several exceptions
as related to statute i i can't i can't
know what i'm going to receive in the
mail next sunday monday or not sunday
monday and tuesday
i'm statutorily required to count those
ballots if they're postmarked by the
third
we have provisional ballots that are
going to go in all of the exceptions
that i mentioned
those are ballots that will be counted
anybody that was eligible and they
casted a ballot and provided us anything
they needed to provide
their ballot will be counted by november
12th
did i i don't have observers it's the
general public that comes in and
observes i i don't add observers
you need to speak up ma'am
absolutely not we've been working close
with all parties who've been interested
in observing our activities in fact
we've gone above and beyond what the
statute calls for us to do
the only thing clark county needs to do
required by law
is to provide access to anyone who wants
to observe us counting
we realized with the engagement by the
general public in this election
that they were going to be concerned and
probably want to see more so we
as a courtesy provided more observation
opportunities
in other rooms now these groups have
also been contacted on a regular basis
and they continue to say that we're not
communicating with them we started
communicating with them in the month of
august
and september and we made clear to them
exactly what we would do
we set up a schedule to count and it's a
worst case scenario
because we want to make sure that we've
got all of our bases covered
and we're going to have staff available
to complete each task each step
every day obviously my staff is getting
better at what they do because they've
been doing
it for over 20 days now so if we finish
before
our scheduled time and there's no more
work they're done
and so we have notified observers who've
come up there's nothing to observe and
we've been even gone so far as to tour
them
and take them to see the area to confirm
that there's nothing going on
unfortunately there are some observers
that come through
that take it upon themselves to go into
areas that they're not allowed to view
interact with our workers what they're
not allowed to do we clearly
communicate to them exactly what they
can and can't do with observers so no we
have done everything we possibly can in
clark county
to allow observers to participate
one more question we're going to take
one day
today same day
same day mail ballots were both what do
you mean by same day
voting
all of the in-person votes are in the
system so okay so ballots reported today
or drop off by mail ballots is that
correct
some of them they're they're grouped in
different areas i can't tell you exactly
which ballots went in and got counted
how come you're not able to say that i
would have to go look at the batches and
see where they came from what i'm
telling you is exactly what we know we
have
left this could be a combination of
drop-off ballots things that were left
in the mail
that's all we really have left at this
point but today
reporting today again in-person voting
was reported on election night that
would have been early voting on election
day all of the in-person votes are in
the system
thanks sir thank you very much we'll see
you tomorrow morning